منذ ان دقه روسيا ابواب الحرب في اوكرانيا
تدفق كم نهائي من شحنه الاسلحه الغربيه
على ماده تسعه اشهر من الحرب ترسانه رغم
ضخمتها فان الغرب متعطش لارسال المزيد
منها وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه اعلنت مؤخرا
انها تدرس اقتراح من شركه بوينج لتزويد
اوكرانيا بقنابل دقيقه صغيره ورخيصه يتم
تثبيتها على صواريخ متوفره بكثره اسلحه
متقدمه تسمح لكيف بتوجيه ضربات خلف الخطوط
الروسيه يطلق عليها اسم قنبله ذات قطر
صغير تطلق من الارض هي واحده من نحو الست
خطط لانتاج ذخيره جديده لاوكرانيا وحلفاء
واشنطن في اوروبا الشرقيه رغم ان موشنت
نرفض الطلبات كيف لتوفير صواريخ يصل مداها
2007 297 كلم فان مدى القنابل لمحل البحث
يبلغ 150 كيلو متر ما يتي اوكرانيا ضرب
اهداف عسكريه حيويه صعبه ومواصلتها جمتها
المضاده لكنها تحتاج لعمليه دقيقه تبدا
بحساب المسافات المراد استهدافها انطلاقا
من الحدود الروسيه
لكنه يعاني من معظمه خطيره اصطدمت بها
واشنطن كذلك وهي حقيقه ان اسلحه الغرب
تتلف سريعا باوكرانيا حسب ما اكد مسؤولون
امريكيون اوكرانيون لموقعه يوزر ثالث
واحترقت عشرات المدافع والصواريخ بعد اشهر
قليله اما بسبب الاستخدام المفرط او
الاقتتال العنيف وحتى سوء الاستعمار